bonsoir aussi les titres de l'actualité
de ce 9 février
finalement le surplus de la cagnotte
dans la casse tête des caisses de l'état
est annoncée par celui ci comme un bonus
de 30 milliards 700 millions de francs
sur ce qu'il faut en faire sur ce que le
ministre du budget prévoit nous vous
donnons toutes les explications
modifications importantes au projet de
loi sur la présomption d'innocence est
examiné aujourd'hui par les députés
parmi les avancées la possibilité de
faire appel d'une condamnation en cour
d'assises s'est dit surtout de
réaffirmer que l'on est présumé innocent
nous vous raconteront l'histoire d'un
général de division aérienne victime de
la machine judiciaire enquête en
andalousie de nos envoyés spéciaux sur
des faits de racisme ordinaire qui ont
provoqué des blessures par balles parmi
les immigrés marocains
une mère de famille à mulhouse convoqué
au tribunal pour défaut d'éducation la
suite de délits répétés commis par trois
de ses enfants âgés 12 14 et 16 ans les
malheurs de limoges le club de basket
pourrait bientôt s'arrêter à la suite
d'une véritable tourmente financière
mais un sur six est encore tôt si nous
serons en direct de limoges pour ce qui
pourrait être la des derniers matches du
club
donc c'est 30 milliards 700 millions de
francs finalement après des semaines de
suspense et de controverses de
diagnostic ressemblant un pari mutuel
permettant de confirmer aux yeux de tous
que les comptes faits à bercy au
ministère des finances sont décidément
repas qu christian sautter a parlé le
chiffre annoncé de surcroît de surcoût
de recettes fiscales permettent une
baisse du déficit du budget de la france
voilà pour le haut et puis comme on a
enlevé le bas et va maintenant on peut
annoncer une baisse de la taxe
d'habitation et le vote d'un collectif
budgétaire au printemps
explication jean bernard schmidt yann
genty et frédéric de large et un brin de
cohue
un zeste d'impatience et un numéro de
duettiste sous les projecteurs
après des mois d'attentes christian
sautter ministre de l'économie et
florence parly secrétaire d'état au
budget ont mis fin à un suspense
insoutenable montant de la cagnotte
fiscale
30 milliards 700 millions de francs
enfin dévoilé le niveau atteint par les
recettes fiscales supplémentaires de
1999 un surplus due à la croissance et
aux excellentes rentrées de l'impôt sur
les sociétés notamment
résultat le déficit budgétaire de l'état
est ramené à 2 106 milliards de francs
cette baisse du déficit permet que pour
la première fois depuis 20 ans la dette
publique va reculer par rapport à la
production nationale nous avons inversé
une courbe de la dette publique qui
montaient va maintenant diminuer
en attendant d'effacer la dette le
gouvernement dispose aujourd'hui d'une
marge de manoeuvre qui va lui permettre
de réajuster le budget 2000 en cours
d'année c'est ce que l'on appelle un
collectif budgétaire avec notamment au
programme une réforme et une baisse de
la taxe d'habitation
un rapport est d'ailleurs attendu sur la
question pour le 30 avril la baisse
d'impôt est ainsi toujours prévu le
gouvernement a promis 120 milliards
d'allègements fiscaux en trois ans fort
de cette annonce des 30 milliards 700
millions de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires les élus de droite et de
gauche sont évoquées aujourd'hui ce
qu'il conviendrait en faire selon le
souhait et réactions rassemblés par
arnaud boutet alban nicosie frédéric de
large
depuis quelques jours tout le monde
parle cagnotte cas cet excédent
budgétaire
mais que faire de cet argent au ps on
envisage de baisser la taxe d'habitation
non pas la supprimer totalement comme le
désir laurent fabius
mais la réduire de manière définitif la
taxe d'habitation est un impôt très très
injuste qui repose sur des bases
injustes
il est payé par par beaucoup de français
et justement la difficulté c'est qu'il
faut que nous leur fassions bien
comprendre que la mesure que nous
prenons et n'est pas seulement
conjoncturel ça doit pas être une mesure
a un coût c'est une mesure durable les
verts et les communistes souhaitent une
augmentation des dépenses sociales
c'est-à-dire relever les minima et
donner plus de moyens aux hôpitaux et à
l'éducation nationale ait un sens il se
dégage de l'argent avec la relance il
faut déjà penser en priorité à ceux qui
vraiment en ont besoin et bien non le
moins à ceux qui souffrent le plus à
droite on veut favoriser la croissance
en baissant la tva
cela concernerait les entreprises et les
particuliers mais ce n'est pas tout les
députés réclament aussi une baisse d un
coup la conjoncture est tellement bonne
pour profiter pour l'accélérer et la
baisse de la tva jouerait ce rôle et
puis sur la beaujoire
il est perçu comme fait lourd par les
français enfin certains députés
définissent d'une autre priorité la
réduction des déficits publics
il n'y a pas de cagnotte qui se font
rappeler qu'il ya plus de 200 milliards
de déficit du budget de l'état sans
compter les dettes dissimulé et
l'accumulation des dettes d'état
française monsieur gouvernement connaît
toutes ces propositions mais il reste
maître du jeu et compte le prouver lors
du débat sur le collectif budgétaire
prévu au printemps
alors pascal golomer on a tout à peu
près entendu sur ce chiffre de la
cagnotte on est passé de 13 milliards et
quelques mois 67 milliards il ya
quelques jours alors le chiffre de 37 un
chiffre correct à correct peut-être pas
très élevé mais c'est sans doute le site
le chiffre politiquement correct que
souhaitait présenter le gouvernement pas
trop élevés pour ne pas donner trop de
poids aux critiques les critiques venues
de droite quant au niveau excessif des
impôts critiques venues de gauche
également quant aux dépenses
insuffisantes à destination des
populations les plus défavorisées mais
le chiffre est suffisamment important
malgré tout pour permettre au
gouvernement d'afficher une diminution
sans précédent du déficit budgétaire
alors ce chiffre est-il sincère ou y at
il eu de savants tour de passe-passe de
dernière minute en tout cas ils sont
nombreux ici à l'assemblée nationale à
droite comme à gauche a réclamé
désormais davantage de transparence lors
de la présentation du budget alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est de comparer
avec 6 passes en allemagne car le
chancelier schröder vient aussi de
décider d'une baisse d'impôts mais c'est
vrai c'est le hasard du calendrier le
chancelier allemand a annoncé une
réduction record des impôts à la fois à
destination des particuliers à
destination des entreprises 244
milliards de francs d'allègements en
cinq ans c'est beaucoup c'est deux fois
plus que ce qu'a annoncé la france il
est vrai pour une période de trois ans
seulement mais cela va se donner sans
doute des arguments à tous ceux qui
réclament de la part du gouvernement
jospin
une vraie réforme fiscale ce soir on l'a
dit christian sautter ne promet
simplement qu'une réforme un allègement
de la taxe d'habitation pour septembre
prochain
ce qui est certain c'est que si les
allège les recettes fiscales continuent
d'augmenter dans les mois qui viennent
ce qui est probable compte tenu de la
croissance économique annoncée est bien
le mot cagnotte risque de réapparaître
très rapidement dans le vocabulaire
politique
merci parce qu'elle le devrait connaître
d'ici la fin du mois de février les
réponses des syndicats de la fonction
publique au projet d'accord-cadre sur
les 35 heures présenté la nuit dernière
par
ministre emile zuccarelli plusieurs
syndicats évoquent des avancées mais
d'autres blocs sur l'absence de création
réelles d'emplois à l'assemblée
nationale les députés examinent depuis
la fin de cet après midi le texte du
projet de loi sur la présomption
d'innocence est une deuxième lecture ou
apparemment droite et gauche se
retrouvant seulement des efforts en
faveur des libertés publiques la droite
qui voit les effets de son action mais
elisabeth guigou ne se sent pas pour
autant désavouer le projet modifie très
nettement la procédure pénale en faveur
du respect de la présomption d'innocence
proporta philippe boisserie et rémy
poissonnier cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale l'ambiance était aussi feutrée
que le ton était cordiale on avait du
mal à croire qu'il y à trois semaines
seulement la réforme de la justice
s'offrait un joli fracas avec l'échec de
la réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
il peut dire que le texte sur la
présomption d'innocence arrive en
deuxième lecture sérieusement augmenté à
l'origine le projet d'elisabeth guigou
prévoyait notamment l'instauration d'un
juge chargée de décider de la mise en
détention provisoire
la présence d'un avocat dès la première
heure de garde à vue le renforcement du
statut de témoin assisté ou encore
l'interdiction de diffuser certaines
photos la cour d'assises est l'objet de
l'avancée la plus spectaculaire
une avancée que les sénateurs avaient
inscrits lorsqu'il avait étudié la loi
désormais il sera possible de faire
appel des verdicts d'une cour d'assises
autre modification la détention
préventive est une nouvelle fois
restreinte
tout comme les cas de mise en examen
sont limitées les délais d'instruction
devront être accéléré quant aux gardes à
vue elles seraient dorénavant enregistré
sur bande magnétique
la structure du texte elle était là
depuis le début
toutes les mesures phares qui vont être
adopté demain était là depuis le début
y compris l'appel de la cour d'assises
et ensuite on a amélioré
il ya eu des amendements du gouvernement
il ya eu des amendements de la majorité
de l'opposition d'ailleurs que j'ai
accepté je crois que c'est un bon
travail parlementaire et gouvernementale
aller-retour une ouverture aux
propositions des parlementaires de
gauche mais aussi de droite qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui certains députés de
l'opposition voteront le texte comme à
l'udf d'autres s'abstiendront sur votre
art il n'y a aucun progrès sérieux il ya
des petites choses dont je ne fais pas
la politique du pire je ne vote pas
contre mais c'est petit jaune suffisent
pas à me satisfaire
ce ton mesuré permettra-t-il de voir
revenir à l'ordre du jour la réforme du
csm et de l'indépendance de la justice
elisabeth guigou promet de ne pas
laisser retomber la flamme
quitte à écorner la cordialité alors
pour illustrer ce qui vient d'être dit
concernant la présomption d'innocence
plutôt la présomption de culpabilité qui
est devenu une pratique courante
judiciaire et médiatique
nous allons vous raconter l'histoire du
général jean-paul chamouton alors que le
débat sur la réforme de la justice
commencé il ya quelques mois notre
chroniqueur judiciaire dominique
verdeilhan recevait une lettre du
général celui ci fut dénoncée en 1988
comme un espion général de division
aérienne titulaire de la légion
d'honneur il fut mis en prison sans que
l'on cherche à vérifier quoi que ce soit
il veut maintenant que son histoire
serve d'exemple l'honneur perdu du
général chamouton en prison depuis deux
jours il est inculpé pour intelligence
avec agents d'une puissance étrangère
après treize ans de silence le général
chamouton acceptée par les sa mise en
examen son incarcération reste une
blessure serviteur de l'état il a été
broyée par l'appareil judiciaire en 1988
général de l'armée de l'air en retraite
il est pdg de la société forest liné une
entreprise spécialisée dans les machines
outils
le 18 avril 88 sur renseignement la dst
l'art est un juge le met en examen et
l'incarcère pour espionnage
jean-paul chamouton restera en prison
trois mois à partir en main le dossier
est vide
pourquoi le juge d'instruction at il
interrogé les gens aussi pourquoi garder
ans
en prison les gens à qui on ne trouve
rien à reprocher en fait le général a
été victime d'une dénonciation
calomnieuse
c'est un ingénieur licencié par
l'entreprise qui a voulu se venger mais
il faudra quatre ans et demi à la
justice pour reconnaître son erreur et
pour qu'un autre juge accorde au général
un non lieu vous apprenez par ont
recommandé que j'avais le non lieu
j'avoue que j'ai été quand même très
très cher près de chez moi même qu'il a
appris ses titres ses articles jean-paul
chamouton a préféré ne pas les lire en
prison alors aujourd'hui il souligne
seulement une énorme disparité un délire
médiatique au moment de son
incarcération auxquels succèdent quatre
ans plus tard une discrétion lors du non
lieu à qui vous en voulez le plus
aujourd'hui à l'état qui a il n'a pas
hésité à envoyer en prison sans
réparation
aucun pardon aucune excuse aucun
dédommagement
le silence de l'état et de la justice
vis-à-vis d'un général qui l'espace 200
jours ne fut plus qu'un matricule
reportage dominique verdeilhan et jean
yves blanc j'évoquais d'hier les émeutes
racistes et les ratonnades en cours en
andalousie la nuit dernière une usine
été incendiée elle et rideaux dans cette
ville des émeutes ont éclaté samedi à la
suite du meurtre d'une jeune femme
espagnole par un malade mental d'origine
marocaine les affrontements qui ont
suivi ont fait plusieurs dizaines de
blessés au delà de ces événements
tragiques nos envoyés spéciaux diego
garcia et patrick descheemaecker ont
recueilli des témoignages d'une
ségrégation ordinaire il y à peu elle et
rideaux étaient une petite ville
tranquille prospère jusqu'à ce que la
folie des hommes
la barbarie raciste passe par la père
venait de l'acheter
ils ont tourné toute la marchandise l
intérieur et puis à brûler le véhicule
voitures brûlées agression détérioration
vandalisme à l écrit dont il ne fait pas
bon être marocain ces jours ci une ville
sans loi le week-end dernier des
centaines d'hommes déchaînée au nom de
la justice saccagent les biens et
brûlent les maisons d'immigrés au dessus
de la boutique
sept personnes ont sauvé leur vie de
justesse ils ont mis le feu
nous on étouffe et il a fallu qu'on
saute par la fenêtre et là ils nous
attendaient avec des pierres et même des
fusils
on a retrouvé ici une quarantaine de
cartouches comme celle ci à quelques
dizaines de mètres de là la police
curieusement a laissé faire pour éviter
je cite les affrontements entre
communautés
aujourd'hui derrière le calme apparent
la tension demeure seule une usine de
recyclage plastique a été incendiés
cette nuit
les espagnols dallaire rideau des
agriculteurs pour la plupart réfute le
mot racisme et préfère parler de
ras-le-bol
à propos des immigrés sont honnêtes pour
la plupart mais il y à 20 % d'immigrés
qui ne viennent pas ici pour travailler
se balade un peu partout pour faire des
mauvais coups
ces chiffres relève plus du fantasme que
de la réalité lé rideau n'est pas au hit
parade de la délinquance dans le pays
si la ville détient un record c'est
celui du nombre de serre horticole c'est
océans de plastique est unique au monde
vingt mille immigrés vivent dans cette
zone sans eux l'activité économique de
la ville s'écroulerait mais pour l'heure
le racisme a détruit même les
bidonvilles dormir à la menthe à la
confiance entre les aujourd'hui la
plupart des travailleurs immigrés est en
grève ici si elle se généralise toutes
les régions cela pourrait avoir de
graves conséquences économiques en
grande-bretagne à stanstead non loin de
londres la prise d'otage des 156
passagers de l'avion afghans continuent
avec un épisode surprenant la fuite de
plusieurs membres d'équipage qui
suscitait quelques nervosité chez les
pirates de l'air récit benoît duquesne
restent-elles nos deux pirates de l'air
armée est semble-t-il masqué qui
supervise le réapprovisionnement de
l'avion c'était tôt ce matin sur
l'aéroport de stanstead
preuve que la situation s'est tendue car
c'est la première fois que les pirates
descente ainsi armé sur la piste il faut
dire que l'épisode de la nuit dernière
les a passablement énervé il est minuit
depuis trois quarts d'heure les lumières
se sont éteintes à bord de l'avion
c'est le moment choisi par quatre
membres de l'équipage dans le commandant
de bord pour brisé l'une des vitres du
cockpit descendre sur le tarmac et
abandonner ainsi l'avion et ses
passagers quand ils s'en rendent compte
quelques heures plus tard les pirates
furieux pouces d'un homme par la porte
arrière lundi stewart toute la journée
la tante s'est prolongée à bord de
l'appareil où se trouve maintenant 150
personnes les pirates seraient au nombre
de six ou dix que veulent t'ils
précisément la police ne le dit pas deux
équipes de négociateurs se relaient en
permanence mais au plus de
revendications politiques précise
n'aurait été exprimées
autour de l'appareil les forces
spéciales des sas sont bien sûr prête à
intervenir
mais pour l'instant les autorités
espèrent toujours résoudre cette crise
sans violence par le dialogue
et alors que les otages s'apprêtent à
passer leur quatrième nuit dans l'avion
s'interrogent de plus en plus sur les
motivations des pirates l'une d'elles
pourrait être tout simplement d'obtenir
l'asile politique ici en angleterre on
sait que la question a déjà été abordé
avec la police ont dit que leurs
familles se trouveraient parmi les
otages
et on rappelle surtout la politique très
favorable de l'angleterre dans ce
domaine par à titre d'exemple il faut
savoir que les pirates qui avaient
détourné un avion irakien ici en 96 se
trouve toujours en angleterre ils sont
libres ils attendent tout simplement que
le gouvernement anglais se prononce sur
leur demande d'asile en tchétchénie les
avions russes ont largué des bombes sur
plusieurs bases supposés de rebelles
dans les montagnes du sud du pays
et puis à l'ouest et au sud de la
capitale grozny d'autres combats ont
actuellement lieu commenté à bernard
lebrun après quatre mois de
bombardements voici à quoi ressemble la
capitale tchétchène
un gigantesque champ de ruines fumantes
ou lentement le silence s'abat un
silence de mort à l'état major on
appelle cela la phase finale
en clair le nettoyage des dernières
poches de résistance 300 combattants
tchétchènes se trouveraient encore à
grossemy attendant pour sortir le retour
des civils afin de quitter la ville plus
discrètement la population civile
justement dix à vingt mille personnes
selon le ministère russe des situations
d'urgence et à en croire ces images les
rescapés seraient désormais pris en
charge par les cantines roulante des
militaires après les bombardements
l'humanitaire menu unique la soupe aux
choux pour ces enfants et ces femmes
peu d'hommes parmi les survivants de
l'horreur nous restons dit cette femme
nous avons toujours vécu ici et puis il
n'y a aucune possibilité de partir
nous n'avons plus d'argent la ville est
privée d'eau de gaz d'électricité depuis
octobre dernier pour autant moscou se
refuse toujours à accepter la présence à
grozny les organisations humanitaires
internationales
sans doute parce qu'en haut lieu on
préfère cacher jusqu'au bout le sale
boulot des soldats russes et il faut
rappeler que c'est dans le sud de la
tchétchénie que serait détenu depuis le
1er octobre dernier le photographe
français brice fleutiaux dont hubert
védrine évoqué le sort lors de sa
dernière rencontre avec vladimir poutine
à moscou
et puis il ya cette affaire difficile à
comprendre d'un journaliste russe andrei
babinski qui aurait été échangé la
semaine dernière contre des militaires
russes prisonniers de rebelles
tchétchènes andrei babbitt ce qu'ils
seraient toujours en vie au milieu des
rebelles une cassette a été présenté par
la chaîne de télévision privée russe ntv
montrant ce journaliste dont des
reportages avait fortement agacé les
généraux de moscou explications de nos
correspondants gilles rabin et france
brice est aujourd'hui 6 février de l'an
2000 pour moi ça va relativement bien
le seul problème c'est le temps en
russie lit à deux mots différents pour
désigner de temps qu'il fait et le temps
qui passe
cette petite phrase le seul problème
c'est le temps qui semble remettre en
cause la date indiquée inquiète les
proches de baby ski d'après ce que nous
avons vu sur la cassette
d'après la façon les circonstances dans
lesquelles nous est parvenue nous
suspectons très fortement qu'elle vient
des russes des attaches à cette cassette
était censée rassurer en réalité
l'inquiète
d'abord parce que l'un des deux hommes
qui n'a apporté portait un uniforme du
ministère de l'intérieur russe ensuite
parce que personne ne sait où quand
comment par qui
cette vidéo de cinquante neuf petites
secondes a été tourné et qu'elles
n'apportent pas la preuve qu andry baby
ski soit vivant aujourd'hui vivant il
était jeudi dernier le jour où ce
journaliste de nationalité russe a été
échangé par l'armée de son pays contre
des soldats prisonniers comme s'il était
un combattant tchétchène
la veille un confrère de radio liberté
avait réussi à lui faire passer sans
pouvoir le rencontrer
un colis dans lequel se trouvait la
chemise qu'il portait ce jour là
qu'est-il devenu depuis et il détenu par
qui ou et pourquoi
une seule chose est sûre radio liberté
qui est financée par le congrès
américain est depuis longtemps l'enjeu
d'une sourde lutte entre les services
secrets russes et américains malgré
l'appel du président américain bill
clinton est une activité diplomatique
notamment de la france et de l'union
européenne israël a de nouveau bombardé
plusieurs sites où se trouveraient des
positions du hezbollah au sud liban le
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères david levy a menacé de mettre
à feu la terre du liban
si le s vous la réplique à vienne le
nouveau chancelier autrichien présenté
son programme de gouvernement il a
notamment annoncé le versement de
compensations aux victimes du travail
forcé sous le nazisme mais dans un
parlement qui était protégé par deux
mille policiers wolfgang schüssel qui
s'est allié avec l'extrême droite a jugé
exagéré et mal informé les critiques de
l'étranger
il ya quelques instants à l'elysée le
président jacques chirac à l'issue d'un
entretien avec le chef du gouvernement
espagnol josé maria aznar a tenu à
rappeler ses prises de position contre
l'extrême droite au pouvoir en autriche
ces valeurs représentent le socle sur
lequel est fondé l'union et en faisant
un accroc important à ce socle
l'autriche
c'est en quelque sorte mis en situation
de rupture de contrat et je le répète
notre condamnation n'est pas une
ingérence
c'est un rappel à l'autriche qui lie à
un contrat auxquels elle a souscrit
lorsqu'elle a adhéré et que ce contrat
doit être respectée et qu'il exclut la
possibilité de développer une idéologie
comme celle dont le parti en question
est porteuse
christian mary mono en fait le président
de la république a saisi cette occasion
de déplacement de monsieur asnar pour
bien rappeler ses positions face à
l'extrême droite
c'est en effet la première réaction
officielle du chef de l'état il faut
rappeler que la france était la première
à initier en quelque sorte la décision
de sanction contre l'autriche après la
constitution du gouvernement avec des
membres d'extrême droite
d'ailleurs le président la commission
européenne romano prodi a rappelé que
les sanctions étaient seulement
bilatérales n'affectait pas le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
le test ce sera vendredi prochain avec
un conseil européen des affaires
sociales avec la participation de la
ministre autrichien des affaires
sociales qui est membre du parti
d'extrême droite en hamouri qui
participera ce conseil a prévenu qu'elle
ignoreraient qu'elles quitteraient la
salle avec son homologue autrichienne
contrat la parole merci et sur marigny
puis ce soir pour ce sommet franco
espagnol durant un dîner officiel tout à
fait originale quel qu'il soit dans un
bistrot du 14e arrondissement de paris
baptisé l'opportun le député maire de
lyon l'ancien premier ministre raymond
barre est hospitalisé depuis dimanche
soir l'hôpital militaire du val de grâce
à paris il a été placé en observation
pour une congestion pulmonaire
et puis la nomination au conseil des
ministres de jean claude cousseran comme
directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure la dgse
c'est une première car monsieur
cousseran est un diplomate
un rapport sur la spoliation des biens
juifs de france sera remis d'ici les
premiers jours de mars au premier
ministre une fondation ou seraient
rassemblées sommes en déshérence
pourrait être créé une commission
présidée par un ancien magistrat pierre
drai étudie actuellement tous les
dossiers individuels des héritiers des
personnes spoliées pendant la guerre 11
décision dont 8 indemnisations déjà été
rendus fannie au vernis pascal caron ont
recueilli le témoignage de celui qui
était alors un très jeune enfant
l'enfant d'une déportée il avait quatre
mois c'est la seule trace de l'enfance
de vladimir
une photo prise dans le camp français de
rivesaltes sa mère y était interné la
dîme iran il ya vu le jour
il doit la vie à une infirmière qui
l'arrachent hauts responsables français
du camp et le place chez une nourrice la
mer s'échapper reprise par la milice
française elle est du dernier convoi de
déportés pour auschwitz où il meurt en
1944 56 ans plus tard vladimir va
toucher 100 mille francs de l'état
français au titre de la spoliation des
biens juifs
c'est la première fois que j'ai un geste
de la france depuis que je suis orphelin
c'est à dire depuis l'âge de 3 ans et
demi et j'ai un poids de moins sur le
coeur sur le plexus et dans la tête je
dors beaucoup mieux qu'avant
c'est la commission dray qui a décidé
d'indemniser comme victimes de
spoliations à cause des législations
anti
et cent mille francs correspondent à
ceux qu'il aurait dû toucher de
l'héritage de sa mère vers la était
couturière à lyon la somme représente la
valeur actualisée de son atelier c'est
avant tout une réparation morale tant
que victime ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir le sentiment qu'on est entendue
c'est ça aussi la justice la réparation
de ce statut lui viti les dossiers de
vladimir ans éclos plus de 1400 autres
attendent encore réparation à lisbonne à
13 à la soupçonnait de trois meurtres de
jeunes femmes en france a fait
opposition la demande d'extradition
présentée par les autorités judiciaires
françaises la procédure pourrait donc
être beaucoup plus longue que prévue
avant le retour éventuel d'orezza là en
france mais exigeance totale et absolue
défaut d'éducation à mulhouse une mère
de famille de 35 ans devra comparaître
devant le tribunal correctionnel le 8
mars prochain à la suite de délits
répéter imputé à trois de ses enfants
âgés de 12 14 et 16 ans une accumulation
de vols et de violences qui a décidé les
juges à la placer en garde à vue dès
hier avant de la convoquer dans pour une
comparution d'un tribunal correctionnel
reportage de thierry curtet et france
vaillants ils ont 12 14 et 16 ans et
sont déjà connus des services de police
depuis de longs mois ci trois
adolescents trois frères vivaient il
faisait vivre leur famille avec leurs
l'ars et dégradations de véhicules les
vols jusqu'à excédé tout un quartier de
mulhouse
vous savez la mer algérien el période où
j'ai alors eu le grand large présent là
cela c'est pareil il fait rien du tout
alors il n'y a pas au-delà du réel pour
accorder un visa après de multiples
avertissements c'est la mer que les
policiers ont fini par mettre en garde à
vue lundi après-midi après une dernière
arrestation de ses enfants elle aurait
affirmé je ne me sens absolument pas
responsables de leurs actes nous avons
retrouvé le plus jeune des trois
adolescents pourquoi ce que est ce que
tu casses et les voitures c'était pour
s'amuser pour trouer de rachat et qu'est
ce que te disait sa maman au nom de quoi
pourquoi vous faites des voitures pour
rien du tout est-ce que tu avais
l'impression que la maman était d'élever
viennent c'est-à-dire qu'elle essayait
elle les salariés n'est pas bon les amis
de la famille il est clair que plus
personne n'exerçait la moindre autorité
ni la mère seule et abandonnée
encore moins le père ça a toujours été
comme ça personne n'a pris le temps de
discuter enfants par enfant voilà ce
qu'est ce que t'as pourquoi tu pleures
pourquoi tu voles pourquoi si pourquoi
sens après une nuit de garde à vue la
mère seule a été présenté ce matin au
tribunal
la mer est considéré qu'en ayant voilà
une partie de responsabilité quant aux
actes qui sont commis par ces enfants
c'est ce qu'on appelle l' abandon moral
ça existait dans le code pénal
ancien dans le code pénal de 1994 c'est
une chose qui n'est pas en soi
particulièrement nouvelle elle a reçu
une convocation il sera jugé le mois
prochain
les enfants eux ont été officiellement
placé en france plusieurs collèges et
lycées sont en grève en ce moment pour
obtenir des moyens supplémentaires en
personnel et en matériel c'est le cas
notamment dans les bouches du rhône dans
l'académie d'aix-marseille mais nous
avons retenu pour ce soir aussi de la
situation d'une école maternelle dans le
quartier des martégaux à marseille
l'école a été construite il ya une
vingtaine d'années c'était pour une
bonne partie du provisoire mais c'est un
proviseur qui se prolonge et les
dizaines d'enfants de cette maternelle
doivent s'accommoder d'un bâtiment
délabré enquête
helen hughes et nathalie gallet chaque
soir après la classe
le même rituel il faut bâcher la
photocopieuse et les travaux des enfants
au kazoo la nuit apporterait la puce car
l'école n'est plus étanche
on souhaite il ya une vingtaine d'années
ce préfabriqué devait être provisoire
mais le provisoire dure sans vraiment
résister et quand le ciel pleure les
enfants se mouiller et après
l'école des martégaux souffre aussi de
son exiguïté trois classes pour 84
élèves une faute de récréation minuscule
et enfante 3 cnete des vélos qui sont
pris d un dortoir humide qui ne peut
accueillir plus de 20 enfants à la fois
quant aux toilettes il ne faut ni être
pressé ni espéré l'intimité
lassé de cette situation les parents
d'élèves ont décidé de frapper fort
depuis cinq ans leurs démarches auprès
de la mairie ou du ministère de
l'éducation sont restées vaines
plus grave lors de son dernier passage
en novembre 97
la commission de sécurité a bien signalé
des risques électriques liées à des
problèmes d'étanchéité du toit mais elle
a donné un avis favorable
alors les parents se sont tous cotisés
pour s'offrir les services d'un avocat
ils ont saisi le tribunal administratif
on me dit que l'eau coule sans la prise
électrique
on peut pas rester insensible conscience
il est arrivé une fois que le directeur
nous appelle pour nous demander son
pouvait garder mon gosse d'après midi
parce que des draps étaient mouillés
humide pour faire la sieste aux enfants
je trouve ça lamentable
à notre époque la justice vient de
désigner un expert
il doit venir inspecter lundi prochain
et du côté de la mairie de marseille
l'urgence de la situation et soudain
prise en france dans quelques jours
des travaux seront faits et j'ai veillé
personnellement et l'école sera
reconstruite d'ici à septembre 2002
voilà qui me semble-t-il devrait donner
satisfaction aux parents d'élèves et aux
quatre vingts élèves de cette école l
approche des élections municipales la
sphère de l'école dé marc thébault
trouve peut-être enfin son épilogue
sur les côtes du morbihan du finistère
et de la loire atlantique des galettes
et des boulettes de fioul lourd venue du
pétrolier erika arrive pas encore tous
les jours les équipes de nettoyage
ramasse cette trace de marée noire
commissaire dnc dans le morbihan
on trouve des plaques de plusieurs
dizaines de centimètres de diamètre
jusque dans le sud du département de
loire atlantique du sport à limoges dans
les milieux du basket on a l'impression
de vivre en sursis le club du sein du
cercle saint-pierre de limoges l'un des
plus prestigieux du basket français est
pris dans une affaire financière qui
pourrait bien lui être fatal didier rose
agent de joueurs qui avaient été mis en
examen et écroués retrouver sa liberté
il se présente comme un bouc émissaire
dans la crise du club de basket
limougeaud commentaires julien est riche
en tout un public toute une ville une
région montre son soutien au csp limoges
le club mythique du basket français est
en pleine crise juridique et financière
le 13 janvier dernier cinq anciens
dirigeants du club sont mises en examen
dit dire aux agents de joueurs et homme
fort du csp mêmes écroué dans le cadre
d'une enquête pour faux et usage de faux
après avoir versé une caution de trois
millions de francs 10 des rosés remise
en liberté
aujourd'hui il cherche à rétablir sa
dignité son honneur reproché d'avoir été
important ça n'est pas une qualificatif
juridique
on peut me reprocher que la majeure
partie des joueurs de limoges et des
secours avec moi ce n'est pas le
qualificatif juridique
je ne pense pas avoir été à aucun moment
que ce soit à la périodes 91,97
incriminé le dirigeant de fait de cette
société
le président du club jean paul ii
ferretti à gauche sur l'image cherche
depuis maintenant un mois de nouveaux
sponsors afin d'éviter le dépôt de bilan
dix millions de francs sont nécessaires
pour boucler la saison parce qu'il
continue à y croire les associations de
supporters ont recueilli 100 mille
francs de dons et les joueurs du club
ont accepté de réduire leur salaire de
30 à 70%
bayonne
on vous donne aurait largement compensé
tous ceux qui aiment le club de limoges
et ils sont nombreux dans la région
espère vibrer encore longtemps aux sons
et panier du csp et ce soir le cercle
saint-pierre de limoges rend compte en
quarts à c'était un quart de finale
aller de la coupe européenne la korac
on attend une éventuelle bonne nouvelle
alexandre kara oui voyez derrière moi le
match va commencer et on a pris une
bonne nouvelle il y à quelques minutes
de la bouche du président du club jean
paul de peretti qui a annoncé que le
club était en négociations avec un gros
sponsor de la région alors résultats
immédiate le csp va pouvoir jouer les
deux prochains matches ce week-end le
match de championnat face à dijon et la
semaine prochaine le match retour face à
ankara
mais il est clair qu'aujourd'hui le csp
est encore très près du dépôt de bilan
puisqu'on sera le 15 février
s'il peut terminer la saison ou pas donc
le csp est bien un club en sursis c'est
alexandre du cyclisme à présent avec le
numéro un mondial laurent jalabert qui
est de retour dans une course sur le
territoire français il est au tour
méditerranéen avec l'intention de faire
taire rumeur est mécontent après toutes
les histoires de dopage et avec aussi un
objectif l'équipe de france reportage
florent gautreau et pierre lepetit
c'est le retour du fils prodige l'enfant
de mazamet n'avait plus couru en france
depuis 18 mois
jalabert n'a jamais voulu se soumettre
au suivi longitudinal imposé par la
fédération française de cyclisme
le conflit l'avait conduit à prendre une
licence en suisse et à ne plus s'engager
dans les courses françaises
il avait même dû renoncer à porter le
maillot de l'équipe de france
aujourd'hui l'heure est à l'apaisement
je suis content d'être ici même façon je
suis content d'être en espagne en italie
ou en belgique quand jean de la bourse
je pense le tour méditerranéen une belle
participation
c'est surtout ce qui nous réjouit moi
c'est sur le sol français s'inquiétait
surtout noise olin sa dernière
apparition en france remonte au 29
juillet 98 ce jour là le peloton
s'arrête sur la route d'aix les bains
avant de repartir
jalabert lui quitte le tour ulcérés par
les rumeurs de dopage est semble-t-il
inquiets après les perquisitions opérées
par la police depuis l'espagne a adopté
jalabert qui n'a pas perdu son temps il
a retrouvé sa place de numéro un mondial
entre temps la fédération française a
convaincu l'union cycliste
internationale de s'engager dans la
lutte antidopage et les équipes
espagnoles ont accepté l'idée d'un suivi
plus précis
jalabert n'est plus un étranger dans son
pays il envisage même de courir le
prochain tour de france
nous arrivions à la fin de cette
émission je vous rappelle l'actualité à
savoir l'annoncé au ministère des
finances il surplus de recettes fiscales
de l'état qui se monte à 30 milliards
700 millions de francs selon monsieur
sauteur pas ce que vient d'annoncer la
mise l'économie qui prévoit un collectif
budgétaire et une baisse de la taxe
d'habitation
et puis les déclarations de jacques
chirac qui estime que l'autriche les
patients rupture de contrat dans l'union
européenne
la météo dans quelques secondes c'est
avec nathalie rihouet puis gérard klein
avec l'intimité à 22h35 jean luc delarue
avec une question vivre dans le mensonge
à quel prix les erreurs 35 laurence
ostolaza pour le dernier journal de
rédaction suivies des mots 2008 philippe
lefait qui aura comme invité elisabeth
badinter et brigitte fontaine demain à
7,50 françoise laborde recevra le miz
fonction publique emile zuccarelli qui à
13 heures vous trouverez carole gaessler
et rachid arhab à demain 20h bonsoir
merci
je